This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. As we wrote this script, wildfires were ripping through Northern California, burning millions of acres and filling our beautiful city with smoke. At the same time, across the country, a massive tropical storm bore down on the Gulf Coast, and Phoenix, Arizona, recorded its 50th day of the year above 110 degrees. We know that these stories are connected to a bigger story and honestly trying to keep on top of all the bad climate news can be unbearably depressing. They're the kind of headlines that make you want to just not click.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在我们撰写这篇稿子时，野火正席卷北加州，烧毁了数百万英亩的土地，并将我们美丽的城市笼罩在烟雾之中。与此同时，在全国另一端，一场巨大的热带风暴正向墨西哥湾沿岸袭来，而亚利桑那州的凤凰城记录下了今年第50个气温超过110华氏度（约43.3摄氏度）的日子。我们知道，这些事件都与一个更大的议题相关，老实说，试图跟进所有关于气候的坏消息会让人感到无比压抑。这些标题总是让人只想避开，不愿点击。
And so when it seems like there's a piece of genuinely good environmental news, I always smash that link. Best producer Emmett Fitzgerald. Solar power prices at an all-time low. Endangered tigers making a comeback. Exxon mobile doing so poorly gets taken off the Dow Jones. And one morning in the summer of 2019, right after the warmest June and the history of June, I got a surprise dopamine hit when I saw this headline. Tree planting has mind-blowing potential to tackle climate crisis.
所以，每当出现真正好的环境新闻时，我总是会毫不犹豫地点击链接。最佳制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。太阳能价格创下历史新低。濒危老虎数量回升。埃克森美孚表现太差被剔除出道琼斯指数。2019年夏天的某个早晨，就在经历了有记录以来最热的六月之后，我看到了这个标题，感到一阵意想不到的多巴胺冲击：植树造林在应对气候危机方面具有令人惊叹的潜力。
Now, to be perfectly clear, the most mind-blowing thing we could do to tackle the climate crisis is to stop burning fossil fuels. But there are also ways that we can soak up some of the CO2 that we've already put into the atmosphere. We're developing machines to do this, but trees and other plants actually do it naturally. They take in carbon from the atmosphere and store it in their leaves and branches and trunks. And so some scientists in Switzerland tried to calculate how much carbon could be removed if we planted as many trees as possible all around the world.
现在，为了说得更清楚一点，我们应对气候危机最令人惊叹的做法是停止燃烧化石燃料。但我们也可以通过一些方法来吸收我们已经排放到大气中的部分二氧化碳。我们正在开发机器来做这件事，但树木和其他植物实际上是自然地完成这一过程的。它们从大气中吸收碳，并将其储存在叶子、树枝和树干中。因此，瑞士的一些科学家试图计算，如果我们能在世界各地尽可能多地种植树木，到底能清除多少碳。
Bay publics to paper in the journal Nature, arguing that if humans planted a trillion trees, it could remove one third of all the CO2 we had put up there in the first place. It was a dramatic finding that led to a lot of dramatic headlines. And the way the paper was being described, you would think that trees were some kind of climate change panacea, that they were the key to fixing global warming. And in the months that followed it felt like the tree planting theory was being aggressively put into practice. Plant a tree to fight the effects of fossil fuels. We start in Ethiopia where a huge campaign has been launched to plant more than 4 billion trees this summer.
他们在《自然》杂志上发表了一篇论文，论证说如果人类种植一万亿棵树，就能清除我们排放到大气中三分之一的二氧化碳。这是一个戏剧性的发现，引发了许多戏剧性的标题。按照论文被描述的方式，你会认为树木是某种气候变化的灵丹妙药，是解决全球变暖的关键。在接下来的几个月里，植树造林的理论似乎被积极地付诸实践。种一棵树来对抗化石燃料的影响。我们从埃塞俄比亚开始，那里发起了大规模运动，计划在今年夏天种植超过40亿棵树。
Volunteers in India planted more than 66 million trees in just 12 hours in a record breaking. There's even a tree planting anthem. Eventually, the tree planting gospel found the unlikliest of champions. Make it swan, it's real young, little baby, baby Eventually the tree planting gospel found the unlikliest of champions President Donald Trump expressed his love of tree planting at the world economic forum and then Trump, the man who pulled the US out of the Paris climate treaty, signed on to something called the Trillion Trees Initiative On Earth Day, President Trump gathered the press on the White House lawn to watch him plant a tree of his own.
印度的志愿者在短短12小时内种植了超过6600万棵树，打破了纪录。甚至还有一首植树赞歌。最终，植树福音找到了最不可能的拥护者。最终，植树福音找到了最不可能的拥护者。唐纳德·特朗普总统在世界经济论坛上表达了他对植树的热爱，随后，这位将美国撤出《巴黎气候协定》的特朗普，签署了一项名为“万亿树木倡议”的计划。在地球日，特朗普总统召集媒体来到白宫草坪，观看他亲手种下一棵树。
As a sign of our dedication in a few moments, the first lady and I will plant a maple tree right here on the south lawn of the White House, and wherever the tree is, where is this tree now? That's a beautiful street trunk. That's a triple A tree. The triple A tree was already in the ground, but the president, the first lady, members of cabinet,
作为我们奉献的标志，片刻之后，第一夫人和我将在这里，在白宫南草坪种下一棵枫树，无论这棵树在哪里，这棵树现在在哪儿？那是一棵漂亮的树干。那是一棵3A级的树。这棵3A级的树已经种在地里了，但总统、第一夫人、内阁成员们，
picked up their golden shovels and threw some dirt in the hole. OK. I'm not a good expert at everything. I'm not a good expert. Now, don't get me wrong. I don't have anything against trees. In fact, I love trees, just as much as the next outdoorsy guy from Vermont. But I've also been reporting on climate change long enough to know that there are no silver
拿起他们的金铲子，往坑里填了一些土。好吧。我不是什么专家。我不是什么专家。现在，别误会我的意思。我并不反对树木。事实上，我和任何来自佛蒙特州的户外爱好者一样热爱树木。但我报道气候变化的时间足够长，我知道这世上没有万能的
bullets. And the way people were talking about tree planting felt, you know, a little simplistic. It was like, here's this enormously complicated issue, climate change. And we're just going to boil it down to a slogan. Plant trees, save the earth. Well, whenever I hear that phrase, all that discourse, my stress level goes up enormously. This is Richard Lindsay,
灵丹妙药。人们谈论植树的方式，你知道，感觉有点过于简单化了。就像是说，气候变化是一个极其复杂的问题，而我们只是把它简化成了一个口号：种树，拯救地球。好吧，每当我听到这句话，听到所有这些论调时，我的压力水平就会急剧上升。这是理查德·林赛，
a scientist at the University of East London sustainability research institute. Everybody is saying, let's plant a million trees. Let's plant a billion trees. Yes, I'm all in favor of that, but let's plant the right tree in the right place. And Richard has personal experience watching a lot of trees get planted in the wrong place. Back in the 1980s, he saw firsthand the impacts of a controversial tree planting scheme in Scotland that ended up threatening one of the most special ecosystems in the world.
东伦敦大学可持续发展研究所的科学家。每个人都在说，让我们种一百万棵树，让我们种十亿棵树。是的，我完全赞成，但让我们在正确的地方种正确的树。理查德有亲眼目睹许多树木被种在错误地方的个人经历。早在20世纪80年代，他就亲眼目睹了苏格兰一项有争议的植树计划所带来的影响，该计划最终威胁到了世界上最特殊的生态系统之一。
The trees weren't being planted to fight climate change. I want to be really clear about that. Very few people were talking about climate change back then. But the story of what happened in Scotland should still serve as a cautionary tale for our tree planting efforts today, because forests aren't the only ecosystems that store carbon. And so when we do plant trees, we need to be really careful about where we're planting them
这些树并不是为了应对气候变化而种植的。我想明确这一点。那时很少有人谈论气候变化。但苏格兰发生的事情的故事，仍然应该作为我们今天植树造林努力的警示故事，因为森林并不是唯一储存碳的生态系统。所以，当我们种植树木时，我们需要非常小心我们种植它们的地方，
and what happens after they go in the ground. The British Isles used to be covered in forests, but after centuries of converting forest land to agriculture, the iconic British woodland was largely a thing of the past. By the 20th century, Great Britain was importing wood because it didn't have enough of its own. And so, in the 1980s, the government started using tax breaks to encourage private citizens to fund tree planting efforts
以及它们种下之后会发生什么。不列颠群岛曾经被森林覆盖，但在几个世纪将林地转为农业用地之后，标志性的英国林地已基本成为过去。到了20世纪，英国因为自身木材不足而开始进口木材。因此，在20世纪80年代，政府开始利用税收减免来鼓励私人资助植树造林工作，
around the country. The goal was to boost the UK's timber supply. And it was a really good tax break, especially for the super rich. So we had people like, well, the band, Genesis, their accountants, got them involved in this. Yes, a number of sort of high profile names who all invested in this, having been convinced that it was
遍布全国。目标是增加英国的木材供应。这是一个非常好的税收减免政策，尤其是对超级富豪而言。所以我们有像，嗯，创世纪乐队（Genesis）这样的人，他们的会计师让他们参与了进来。是的，一些知名人士都投资了这项计划，因为他们被说服了，认为这是一件
a good thing because, of course, planting trees is a good thing. Is it not? But questions started to emerge about where exactly these trees were going to go. In order for this to work, investors needed large tracks of undeveloped, unwanted land. And there was one place that met that criteria perfectly. It was called the Flow Country. The Flow Country is a vast open area in far north of Scotland that looks almost like the Arctic Tundra.
好事，因为当然，种树是一件好事，不是吗？但关于这些树到底要种在哪里，开始出现疑问。为了使这项计划奏效，投资者需要大片未开发的、无人想要的土地。有一个地方完美符合这些标准。它被称为“流之国”（Flow Country）。流之国是苏格兰最北端一片广阔的开阔地，看起来几乎就像北极苔原。
The term Tundra comes from the Finnish word Tundtree, which means beyond the tree line. And so that really tells you something about the overall landscape. It's essentially treeless. The flow country is what's called a blanket bog. It's actually the largest blanket bog in all of Europe. The best way to appreciate the landscape
“苔原”（Tundra）一词来自芬兰语“Tunturi”，意思是“树线之外”。所以这确实说明了整体景观的一些情况。它基本上是没有树的。流之国被称为“毯状泥炭沼泽”。它实际上是整个欧洲最大的毯状泥炭沼泽。欣赏这种景观的最好方式
might be in an airplane. From the sky, it looks like a Persian rug streaked with colorful svagnum mosses and dotted with little pools of water. Well it's harder to appreciate when you're on the ground. The majority of the landscape will be this wet, boggy, soft, a really quite colorful carpet of bog mosses. So as you walk across it, it's a bit like walking across a sprung mattress, except you need rubber boots. Yeah, a soggy, a soggy mattress.
可能是在飞机上。从空中看，它看起来像一张波斯地毯，上面布满了色彩斑斓的泥炭藓，点缀着小水池。嗯，当你站在地面上时，就很难欣赏了。大部分景观都是这种潮湿、泥泞、柔软、色彩相当丰富的泥炭藓地毯。所以当你走在上面时，有点像走在弹簧床垫上，只是你需要穿橡胶靴。是的，一个湿漉漉的、湿漉漉的床垫。
Sogy is a very good word for it. Yes. There's a saying in Scotland that summer is the best day of the year. It's cold in damp and gets an enormous amount of rainfall. But otherwise, it's perfect. It truly is one of my favorite places on earth. Yeah, and beautiful Scotland's terrible weather actually creates the perfect conditions
“湿漉漉”是一个很好的词。是的。苏格兰有句谚语说，夏天是一年中最美好的一天。那里又冷又潮湿，降雨量巨大。但除此之外，它很完美。它确实是我在地球上最喜欢的地方之一。是的，苏格兰美丽的糟糕天气实际上创造了完美的条件，
for an incredible substance to form. It's called Pete and it's what the flow country is made of. The land is so saturated, there's very little oxygen, and it's really hard for plant matter to break down. And so over thousands and thousands of years, this partially decomposed material, or peat, has been slowly accumulating. In some parts of the flow country, the peat is now more than 30 feet deep. And the amazing thing about peat from a climate perspective is that it stores a ton of carbon. I fell in love with peat lands because they are these beautiful ecosystems, but they also are
让一种不可思议的物质形成。它被称为“泥炭”，这就是流之国的构成。土地如此饱和，几乎没有氧气，植物物质很难分解。因此，经过成千上万年，这种部分分解的物质，即泥炭，一直在缓慢积累。在流之国的一些地方，泥炭现在有30多英尺深。从气候角度来看，泥炭的神奇之处在于它储存了大量的碳。我爱上了泥炭地，因为它们是美丽的生态系统，但它们也是
global powerhouses for carbon storage. This is Merit Turetski, or the Queen of Pete, as she's known on Twitter. She's the director of the Institute of Arctic and Alpine Research at UC Boulder, and she says that Petelands are like these dense underground pockets of carbon. So the amount of carbon stored in Petelands on a meter square basis is often 10 times, 15 times higher than that same area of land in a forest or in an agricultural setting. These are true hot spots when it comes to protecting carbon in soils and keeping that carbon out of the atmosphere. Peatlands around the world actually contain more carbon than all the worlds of vegetation
全球碳储存的动力源。这是梅里特·图雷茨基，或者正如她在推特上所知的那样，是“泥炭女王”。她是科罗拉多大学博尔德分校北极和高山研究所的主任，她说泥炭地就像这些密集的地下碳口袋。因此，在每平方米的基础上，泥炭地中储存的碳量通常比森林或农业环境中的同一块土地高出10到15倍。当谈到保护土壤中的碳并将其阻挡在大气之外时，这些是真正的热点。世界各地的泥炭地实际上包含的碳比世界上所有的植被
combined. But back in the 80s, most people didn't know about this incredible power of Pete. If anything, bogs were seen as unpleasant, scary places to be avoided. In part, because they were filled with dead people, ancient bog bodies that had been pickled for centuries in the anaerobic muck. Some of these bodies appear to be ritual sacrifices from the bronze and iron ages. Once those bodies were tossed into the bog, they became very efficiently preserved. Because of those same conditions that protect Pete from decomposition, the bog bodies didn't
加起来还要多。但在80年代，大多数人并不知道泥炭的这种不可思议的力量。如果说有什么不同的话，沼泽被视为令人不快、可怕的地方，应该避开。部分原因是它们里面充满了死人，即在厌氧泥浆中腌制了几个世纪的古代沼泽尸体。其中一些尸体似乎是青铜时代和铁器时代的祭祀品。一旦这些尸体被扔进沼泽，它们就会被非常有效地保存下来。由于保护泥炭免受分解的相同条件，沼泽尸体并没有
decompose. And occasionally these eerily well-preserved corpses would surface from the bogs of Northern Europe. Nilecisse in Scotland, the spooky, soggy, petland wasn't exactly a popular spot. The flow country was known locally by an acronym, Mamba. Famously, it was called Mamba Country.
分解。偶尔，这些保存得令人毛骨悚然的尸体会从北欧的沼泽中浮现出来。在苏格兰，这种阴森、潮湿的泥炭地并不完全是一个受欢迎的地方。流之国在当地被称为一个缩写词：Mamba。它被著名地称为“Mamba之国”。
Miles, miles of bug of Buggerall. And so, in the 1980s, when the forest industry started looking for large tracks of undeveloped land to plant trees, the flow country was an obvious choice. You know, it was seen as a wasteland, so the local people had been convinced by the forest industry that this was going to bring a new economy to the area. So, of course, local people were really excited. What happened next was kind of a race between the forestry groups who started draining the
“Miles and miles of bugger all”（绵延数英里的荒地）。因此，在20世纪80年代，当林业部门开始寻找大片未开发的土地来种植树木时，流之国是一个显而易见的选择。你知道，它被视为荒地，所以当地人被林业部门说服，认为这将为该地区带来新的经济。所以，当然，当地人非常兴奋。接下来发生的事情，就像是林业集团开始排水之间的竞赛，
peat bogs and planting trees and conservation groups who began trying to catalog all the biodiversity in this fragile landscape before it was completely covered up. And that's where I was really sucked into the whole flow country story because essentially I was tasked with running a survey program to establish whether the flow country contained anything of importance, anything that we should be concerned about losing." Richard assembled a team of scientists. They packed up tents and camping gear, cameras and food, and took the train from London, over 400 miles north to the tippy top of Scotland. And right away Richard was taken with the place.
泥炭沼泽和种植树木，以及试图在这些脆弱的景观被完全覆盖之前，对其中的所有生物多样性进行编目的保护组织之间的竞赛。这就是我真正被卷入整个流之国故事的地方，因为本质上，我的任务是运行一个调查项目，以确定流之国是否包含任何重要的东西，任何我们应该担心失去的东西。理查德组建了一个科学家团队。他们收拾好帐篷和露营装备、相机和食物，坐火车从伦敦向北行驶了400多英里，到达苏格兰的最顶端。理查德立刻就被这个地方吸引住了。
It was extraordinary. First of all, in the silence. But pretty quickly, he got acquainted with the sounds and smells of the place too. For weeks, he and his team would trample around on top of the soggy mattress, documenting all of the wildlife in the bog. Carnivorous plants, dragonflies, water beetles, loons, and golden plovers. It was tough going, but apart from the wet socks, Richard remembers these long walks fondly. Because you sort of bounce gently along, there's a sort of squish, squish under foot, and there's a lovely scent of holy hazards and the various sort of flowering plants that
这太非凡了。首先，是在寂静中。但很快，他也熟悉了这个地方的声音和气味。几周来，他和他的团队会在湿漉漉的床垫上践踏，记录沼泽中的所有野生动物。食肉植物、蜻蜓、水甲虫、潜鸟和金鸻。这很艰难，但除了湿袜子，理查德对这些长途跋涉记忆犹新。因为你会轻轻地弹跳，脚下有一种“噗嗤、噗嗤”的声音，周围弥漫着金雀花和各种开花植物的可爱香气，
lofted up around you. And in the end, Richard and his team determined that the flow country wasn't a wasteland at all, but a thriving wetland habitat that had been underappreciated for centuries. Essentially, we found that the range of ecosystem types was like nothing. Well, really, that had been described anywhere else in the world. But as all this was happening, the tree planting was already underway, and so at the same time Richard was discovering the secrets of this delicate landscape, the forestry companies were tearing it up. They plowed up the bogs, strained out all that water, and planted non-native, quick-growing
在你周围升起。最终，理查德和他的团队确定流之国根本不是荒地，而是一个几个世纪以来一直被低估的繁荣湿地栖息地。本质上，我们发现生态系统类型的范围是独一无二的。嗯，真的，这在世界其他任何地方都没有被描述过。但当这一切发生时，植树造林已经在进行中，所以当理查德发现这片脆弱景观的秘密时，林业公司正在摧毁它。他们犁开了沼泽，排干了所有的水，并种植了非本地的、快速生长的
conifers. Pretty soon, little patches of evergreen forests were sprouting up all across the flow country, although Richard says forest isn't really the right word. The plantations, plantations, established with agricultural densities in mind. Rose and rose of sittka sp and Lodgepole pine packed tightly together. In these dense plantations, we're terrible places for native wildlife. They quickly filled up with predators
针叶树。很快，常绿森林的小块区域在整个流之国涌现，尽管理查德说“森林”并不是正确的词。这些种植园，考虑到农业密度而建立的种植园。一排排的西加云杉和扭叶松紧密地挤在一起。在这些密集的种植园里，对于本地野生动物来说是糟糕的地方。它们很快就充满了捕食者，
that scared off many of the birds that Richard and his team were just beginning to learn about. The petalins were turning into a tree farm. So, yeah, pretty, solid is trying. As they did their work, Richard and the other scientists were called to testify in local meetings about the Forestry Project, and they had to argue that this seemingly empty, worthless landscape was actually worth protecting. And essentially, it's our equivalent of the tropical rainforest.
吓跑了理查德和他的团队刚刚开始了解的许多鸟类。泥炭地正在变成一个树木农场。所以，是的，相当令人沮丧。在他们工作时，理查德和其他科学家被传唤在当地会议上就林业项目作证，他们不得不争辩说，这片看似空旷、毫无价值的景观实际上是值得保护的。本质上，这是我们国家热带雨林的等价物。
But the forest industry didn't see it that way. I just have this general memory of being shouted at a lot for a very long time. They were banging the table and they were shouting at us and demanding to know what we thought we were doing. To which our response was, well, we think we're doing our job. And our job was to identify important areas of the nation's wildlife heritage. And that's exactly what we were doing. Was it weird at the time to be arguing that trees were an environmental problem? Oh, that was so difficult. Yes, but, you know, it's like everything, you know, a medication is a good thing when used in the right way, in the right place, used in the wrong
但林业部门并不这么看。我只是有这种普遍的记忆，被大声呵斥了很长一段时间。他们拍着桌子，对我们大喊大叫，要求知道我们认为自己在做什么。对此我们的回应是，嗯，我们认为我们在做我们的工作。我们的工作是确定国家野生动物遗产的重要区域。而这正是我们正在做的。当时争论树木是一个环境问题很奇怪吗？哦，那太困难了。是的，但是，你知道，这就像任何事情一样，你知道，药物在正确的方式、正确的地方使用时是一件好事，在错误的方式、
way, in the wrong place. It's a poison, and that was the tricky message that we had to try and get across. But over time, public opinion began to turn against the tree planting. A lot of that had to do with the fact that it seemed like an egregious form of tax avoidance, but the message about the Petelins was also starting to get through. The government eventually agreed to protect about half
错误的地方使用时，它就是一种毒药，这就是我们必须努力传达的棘手信息。但随着时间的推移，公众舆论开始反对植树造林。这很大程度上是因为它看起来像是一种恶劣的避税形式，但关于泥炭地的信息也开始传开了。政府最终同意保护理查德和他的团队调查过的大约一半
of the Petelins that Richard and his team had surveyed. And then a couple months later, they completely ended the tax scheme. A colleague phoned me and just said, it's gone. I said, what's gone? The first round scheme, it's gone. I don't remember, I had to sit down. I was so surprised.
的泥炭地。几个月后，他们完全结束了这项税收计划。一位同事打电话给我说，它没了。我说，什么没了？那个林业计划，它没了。我不记得了，我不得不坐下来。我太惊讶了。
It was a big win for the bog, and the conservationists fighting to protect it. And in the decades that followed the way people saw the flow country, really started to shift. It went from being a place people avoided to a place that people wanted to see, the largest blanket bog in all of Europe. And people were coming to visit it to see this, this amazing landscape, and all of this gradually chipped away at the idea of this is useless wasteland, and people began to relate to it as their landscape, their precious landscape. But a lot of damage had been done.
这对沼泽和为保护它而战的环保主义者来说是一个巨大的胜利。在随后的几十年里，人们看待流之国的方式确实开始转变。它从一个人们避之不及的地方，变成了一个人们想要去看看的地方，即整个欧洲最大的毯状泥炭沼泽。人们来到这里参观这个令人惊叹的景观，所有这些逐渐打破了“这是无用的荒地”的想法，人们开始将其视为他们的景观，他们珍贵的景观。但很多损害已经造成了。
Over 150,000 acres of the flow country have been drained and planted with trees. These trees never really grew very well. They were short and stubby and not very useful as timber. But the plantations pushed out native wildlife that depended on the bog and damaged the precious peat that was storing all that carbon. And the flow country wasn't the only place where this kind of thing happened.
超过15万英亩的流之国被排干并种上了树。这些树从来没有长得很好。它们又矮又粗，作为木材并不太有用。但这些种植园挤走了依赖沼泽的本地野生动物，并破坏了储存所有碳的珍贵泥炭。流之国并不是唯一发生这种事情的地方。
Chile, to take one example, started incentivizing tree planting around the same time as the UK. And while they did plant a lot of trees, the effort led to a decline in biodiversity and negligible climate benefits. In Alberta, Canada, they drained large swaths of bog in order to plant trees, again, starting in the 80s. But most of those trees burned down in the Fort McMurray Fire of 2016, in part because the once wet ground had been drained dry.
以智利为例，它在大约与英国相同的时间开始激励植树造林。虽然他们确实种植了很多树，但这一努力导致了生物多样性的下降和微不足道的气候效益。在加拿大阿尔伯塔省，他们排干了大片沼泽以种植树木，同样是从80年代开始的。但其中大部分树木在2016年的麦克默里堡大火中被烧毁，部分原因是曾经潮湿的地面被排干了。
Back in the 1980s, Richard Lindsay and his colleagues were only concerned about the biodiversity and the under-appreciated peat bog. But in recent years, as the urgency of the climate crisis grows, there's been an increased focus on carbon storage in ecosystems. Scientists are studying the carbon dynamics and kelp forests and seagrass beds, and Petland's in particular have been getting a lot of attention for their carbon-storing powers. You know you've gone mainstream. When Alec Baldwin is talking about you in a PSA for the UN.
早在20世纪80年代，理查德·林赛和他的同事们只关心生物多样性和被低估的泥炭沼泽。但近年来，随着气候危机的紧迫性增加，人们越来越关注生态系统中的碳储存。科学家们正在研究海带森林和海草床中的碳动态，尤其是泥炭地，因其储碳能力而受到了很多关注。你知道你已经成为主流了，当亚历克·鲍德温在联合国的一则公益广告中谈论你时。
Pete Lans are crucial to fight climate change. And here's the thing about Pete Lans. They matter for the planet because they actually store twice as much carbon as all the world's forest together while covering less than 3% of the land's surface. So Pete Lans are the most efficient terrestrial carbon sink under planet. This is Roxanne Anderson. She's been studying the islands for a while now
泥炭地对于应对气候变化至关重要。关于泥炭地，关键在于：它们对地球很重要，因为它们实际上储存的碳是世界上所有森林总和的两倍，而覆盖的土地面积不到地球表面的3%。所以泥炭地是地球上最高效的陆地碳汇。这是罗克珊·安德森。她研究泥炭地已经有一段时间了，
at the Environmental Research Institute in Scotland. And for decades, it felt like she was laboring away in some obscure corner of academia. She didn't have journalists like me bugging her for interviews, but that's changing. I think this year alone, I must have given something like 15 or 20 interviews. But, in her sense is that when it comes to carbon storage, peelens still don't get the attention that forests do. She thinks it's because
在苏格兰的环境研究所。几十年来，她感觉自己就像在学术界的某个晦涩角落里辛勤工作。她没有像我这样的记者缠着她采访，但情况正在改变。我想仅今年一年，我就一定接受了大约15或20次采访。但是，她的感觉是，当谈到碳储存时，泥炭地仍然没有得到像森林那样的关注。她认为这是因为
all of the carbon in that peatland is below ground. I think that it's because it's not visible. That's why the name of your podcast really resonated. If you look at a forest, you see the trees, you see the vegetation, you see where the carbon is, you see why it's taking up carbon. But even though the carbon in a peatland is hidden underground, it's not locked away forever. Just as a forest can burn down, a peatland can be degraded, can be gobbled up for agriculture, or ranching. And when that happens, a lot of its carbon goes up into the atmosphere, and the carbon sink
泥炭地中所有的碳都在地下。我认为这是因为它不可见。这就是为什么你的播客名字真的引起了共鸣。如果你看一片森林，你会看到树木，看到植被，看到碳在哪里，看到它为什么在吸收碳。但即使泥炭地中的碳隐藏在地下，它也不会永远被锁住。就像森林会被烧毁一样，泥炭地也会退化，会被农业或牧场吞噬。当这种情况发生时，它的大部分碳会进入大气层，碳汇
becomes a carbon source. And that's what happened in the flow country, except in this case, the crop that was gobbling up the peatland was trees. When you drain a peat bog to plant trees, it releases carbon. And then, as the trees grow, their roots impact the way the carbon and the soil is processed. And the carbon losses from the soil can actually exceed the amount of carbon that's taken up in the tree. So planting trees on peets, on deep peets, particularly, is really, really not a good idea.
变成了碳源。这就是流之国发生的事情，只不过在这种情况下，吞噬泥炭地的作物是树木。当你排干泥炭沼泽来种植树木时，它会释放碳。然后，随着树木的生长，它们的根部会影响土壤中碳的处理方式。土壤中的碳损失实际上可能超过树木吸收的碳量。因此，在泥炭上，特别是在深层泥炭上种植树木，真的真的不是一个好主意。
It leads to unintended consequences of basically losing more carbon than you can gain through the trees. And so now, in the flow country, the best thing for the climate may actually be to cut trees down. It's quite claustrophobic being in some of these dark, damp plantations. And so when you start taking them down
它会导致意想不到的后果，基本上损失的碳比通过树木获得的碳还要多。所以现在，在流之国，对气候最好的事情实际上可能是砍掉树木。在这些黑暗、潮湿的种植园里，感觉相当幽闭恐惧。所以当你开始砍掉它们，
and start opening up the landscape again, in some ways it's actually quite cathartic. This is Paul Turner, awarding with the Royal Society for the Protection of Birds. And in 1995 the RSPB purchased a 50,000 acre reserve in the flow country, on land that had been heavily planted with trees. Since then they've been working to restore the bog. We've really spent sort of 25 years trying to repair damage that was done in the sort of 70s and 80s
并开始再次打开景观时，在某些方面，这实际上相当令人宣泄。这是保罗·特纳，在英国皇家鸟类保护协会工作。1995年，RSPB在流之国购买了一个5万英亩的保护区，这片土地上曾被大量种植了树木。从那时起，他们一直致力于恢复沼泽。我们确实花了大约25年的时间试图修复70年代和80年代造成的损害，
to bits of the peatlands. Some of the contractors doing this repair work are actually the same local people who drain the bog back in the 80s. First, they cut the trees down and haul them out. Then, the crucial next step is to re-wet the soil. They build dams in the peat to try to return the water table to its normal level and get that soggy bog back.
对泥炭地的一些部分。进行这项修复工作的一些承包商实际上就是80年代排干沼泽的同一批当地人。首先，他们砍掉树木并把它们运走。然后，关键的下一步是重新润湿土壤。他们在泥炭中建造水坝，试图将地下水位恢复到正常水平，并找回那个湿漉漉的沼泽。
A lot of this work is done with heavy machinery and it does not look pretty. And yeah, you have days where you think actually this is quite a destructive process, but when you start seeing some of the work that we did to attend 15 years ago, it really makes you feel quite good about what you're trying to achieve with it. Roxanne Anderson has studied the box that Paul Turner and the RSPB have restored to try and understand the climate impacts. So what we've found is that when you take trees down
这项工作大部分是用重型机械完成的，看起来并不美观。是的，你会有几天觉得这实际上是一个相当破坏性的过程，但当你开始看到我们10到15年前所做的一些工作时，它真的让你对你试图实现的目标感觉相当好。罗克珊·安德森研究了保罗·特纳和RSPB修复的沼泽，试图了解气候影响。所以我们发现的是，当你砍掉树木
from a people and then do the restoration, initially it reduces carbon. That's not very surprising because of the kind of physical damage that you have to do in terms of cutting the words and everything else. But over the course of decades of restoration, the bogs have switched back from a carbon source to a carbon sink. So effectively returning this kind of carbon benefit or climate benefits of peatlands.
从泥炭地上，然后进行恢复，最初它会减少碳。这并不令人惊讶，因为你在砍伐木材和其他一切方面必须造成的物理损害。但在几十年的恢复过程中，沼泽已经从碳源转回了碳汇。因此有效地恢复了泥炭地的这种碳效益或气候效益。
But as they do this work, Paul Turner keeps running into the same problem that Richard Lindsay did 30 years ago. It's hard to explain to people why trees, in this very specific situation, are bad for the ecosystem. There are a lot of people that don't really understand why we are cutting trees down. It's because surely planting trees is the best thing to do. As I mentioned before, planting trees in the right place is definitely a really good thing to do. Paul is not anti-tree. In fact, the RSPP actually helps manage another piece of land in Scotland
但在他们做这项工作时，保罗·特纳不断遇到理查德·林赛30年前遇到的同样问题。很难向人们解释为什么在这一特定情况下，树木对生态系统有害。有很多人并不真正理解我们为什么要砍树。因为肯定种树是最好的做法。正如我之前提到的，在正确的地方种树绝对是一件非常好的事情。保罗并不反树。事实上，RSPB实际上帮助管理苏格兰的另一块土地，
in the Karingorne Mountains, where they are actively planting trees in an effort to restore the forest and sequester carbon. And the Scottish Government is helping fund both of these efforts. Scotland has a goal of restoring over 600,000 acres of peatbock by 2030. And at the same time, they want to plant 30,000 acres of new forest each year. They are planting trees in one place just as they're cutting trees down in another. It's understanding that not all habitats are equal, that not all habitats should have trees on them, and that when we're talking about climate change mitigation, that one answer doesn't apply to every problem.
在凯恩戈姆山脉，他们正在积极种植树木，试图恢复森林并固碳。苏格兰政府正在帮助资助这两项工作。苏格兰的目标是到2030年恢复超过60万英亩的泥炭沼泽。与此同时，他们希望每年种植3万英亩的新森林。他们在一个地方种树，同时在另一个地方砍树。这是理解并非所有栖息地都是平等的，并非所有栖息地都应该有树木，并且当我们谈论气候变化减缓时，一个答案并不适用于每一个问题。
Forests are great, but they aren't great everywhere. Yeah, I mean, I love forests, but I love other ecosystems too. This is a forest scientist named Forest, Forest Flashtman. Yeah, so I mean, one of the big mistakes that the trillion tree paper made is they sort of said, well, areas without trees don't have carbon. And that's not true because areas without trees have't have carbon. And that's not true because areas without trees have carbon below ground. And not just beetlands, healthy grasslands also store carbon underground. So instead of just thinking about how many trees we can plant, we should be thinking about all the
森林很棒，但它们并非在任何地方都很棒。是的，我的意思是，我热爱森林，但我也热爱其他生态系统。这是一位名叫福雷斯特·弗莱什曼的森林科学家。是的，所以我的意思是，万亿树木论文犯的一个大错误是，他们有点说，嗯，没有树木的地区没有碳。那是不对的，因为没有树木的地区有碳。那是不对的，因为没有树木的地区在地下有碳。不仅是泥炭地，健康的草原也将碳储存在地下。所以，与其只考虑我们可以种植多少棵树，我们应该考虑所有
different ways we can maximize carbon storage in any given landscape without sacrificing biodiversity. That might mean restoring beetlands or protecting healthy grasslands or forests, and That might mean restoring petalins or protecting healthy crashlands or forests, and it might mean planting more trees. And if planting trees is the right thing for a landscape, we're going to have to do more than just plant them. Forest Flitzen has studied tree planting efforts that are being done for climate change, and he's found that often they fail because all of the focus is on that initial act of getting the saplings in the ground.
我们可以在任何给定景观中最大化碳储存的不同方式，而不牺牲生物多样性。这可能意味着恢复泥炭地或保护健康的草原或森林，这可能意味着种植更多的树木。如果种植树木是景观的正确选择，我们将不得不做更多的事情，而不仅仅是种植它们。福雷斯特·弗莱什曼研究了为气候变化而进行的植树造林工作，他发现它们往往会失败，因为所有的焦点都集中在将树苗种在地里的最初行为上。
Because it's something that a politician can walk in and do and get a picture taken and be on the front page of the newspaper or beyond the TV. But then often in the years that follow, those trees get cut down by people or eaten by cows or burned in a fire. So this dialogue, it says, oh, we need to plant a trillion trees. Well, actually, we don't need to plant a trillion trees. Let's say the trillion trees is right.
因为这是政客可以走进去做的事情，可以拍照并登上报纸头版或出现在电视上。但随后在接下来的几年里，这些树往往会被人砍掉，或被牛吃掉，或在大火中烧毁。所以这个对话，它说，哦，我们需要种植一万亿棵树。嗯，实际上，我们不需要种植一万亿棵树。假设一万亿棵树是正确的。
We need to make sure that a trillion trees grow. And making sure that trees grow is more complicated than planting them. Fleischman says the first step is to stop cutting down the healthy forests that we have left. We need to stop illegal logging and boycott the companies that are driving before a station and work to protect the rights of indigenous people who are often the best protectors of forests. And where we do plant new forests, we need to work with local people to make sure that
我们需要确保一万亿棵树能够生长。而确保树木生长比种植它们更复杂。弗莱什曼说，第一步是停止砍伐我们剩下的健康森林。我们需要停止非法采伐，抵制那些推动森林砍伐的公司，并努力保护土著人民的权利，他们往往是森林最好的保护者。在我们种植新森林的地方，我们需要与当地人合作，确保
they benefit from the new trees and are invested in keeping them growing. So when we start thinking about it this way, it really becomes a political and economic problem, not a technical tree planting problem. I think that people get really excited about tree planting in part because it's a solution that seems to exist outside of politics, in economics. It's this simple, natural solution that doesn't require us to pass massive legislation or build a whole new energy system. But the truth is that climate change is fundamentally a complicated, political, and economic, and technological problem.
他们从新树木中受益，并投入精力保持它们的生长。所以当我们开始这样思考时，它确实变成了一个政治和经济问题，而不是一个技术性的植树问题。我认为人们对植树造林感到非常兴奋，部分原因是它是一个似乎存在于政治和经济之外的解决方案。这是一个简单的、自然的解决方案，不需要我们通过大规模的立法或建立一个全新的能源系统。但事实是，气候变化从根本上是一个复杂的、政治的、经济的和技术的问题。
There is no one perfect solution. But we need to solve it anyway. Bugs are the best. We have so many more to talk about bugs. Yes, so one of the things that I found interesting learning all about bugs was all the language around them. You know, you've got so many different words for bogs. Bog, Fen, Meyer, Moore, Marsh, Swamp, Puckassin. This is Merit Turetsky, again, the queen of Pete from our story. And she says that, you know, these aren't synonyms necessarily.
没有一个完美的解决方案。但无论如何，我们需要解决它。沼泽是最棒的。我们还有更多关于沼泽的话题要谈。是的，所以我在了解沼泽时发现有趣的事情之一是围绕它们的所有语言。你知道，你有很多不同的词来形容沼泽。Bog, Fen, Mire, Moor, Marsh, Swamp, Pocosin。这是梅里特·图雷茨基，再次回到我们故事中的泥炭女王。她说，你知道，这些不一定是同义词。
Like, there are subtle differences between all these different words. Some of them are rooted in ecology and wetland classification. Some of them are regional. But there's also this this whole sort of metaphorical side to bog language, wetland language. Like we use a lot of these words a lot actually not in a Pete Lynn science way, but in this kind of more poetic metaphorical sense. And usually bog language connotes metaphorical sense and usually bog language connotes stuckness. Right. Like getting bogged down in something. Yeah. Right. Exactly. But there's a lot of other examples like a quagmire. Well, right. Is it type of bog? And you can get you can get mire in something. A mire is a type of bog or actually, I think a bog is a type of mire. It's like a square rectangle situation.
就像，所有这些不同的词之间有细微的差别。其中一些植根于生态学和湿地分类。其中一些是区域性的。但也有这种泥炭语言、湿地语言的隐喻方面。就像我们实际上经常使用很多这些词，不是以泥炭地科学的方式，而是以这种更诗意的隐喻意义。通常泥炭语言暗示隐喻意义，通常泥炭语言暗示“陷入困境”。对吧。就像陷入某事中。是的。对。完全正确。但还有很多其他例子，比如“泥潭”（Quagmire）。嗯，对。它是沼泽的一种吗？你可以陷入某事中。Mire是一种沼泽，或者实际上，我认为Bog是一种Mire。这就像一个正方形和长方形的情况。
A morass is another word for kind of marshy boggy wetland but also like a confusing situation that you might get stuck in. So what is the explanation for why we use these words so much? When most people probably don't experience bogs on a really regular basis. You know, I think that for Merit Tresky, she says that it's like even though bogs are these places that we don't necessarily spend a lot of time, we've always, humans have always been fascinated by them. And they've always represented this like
“Morass”是另一种形容沼泽湿地的词，但也像你可能陷入的令人困惑的情况。那么，为什么我们如此频繁地使用这些词的解释是什么？当大多数人可能并没有非常频繁地接触沼泽时。你知道，我认为对于梅里特·图雷茨基来说，她说这就像即使沼泽是我们不一定花很多时间的地方，人类也一直对它们着迷。它们一直代表着这种
almost supernatural in-between space. And I think because of the mysteriousness of that, not being land, not being water, not being fully alive, not being fully dead, they are really fascinating to us. And so, bogs in movies, in pop culture, in literature often represent a place where people can hide from society or where you can potentially get lost. And this is totally true in books and movies. Like I remember in Withering Heights, you know, you have the Moors, which are often are presented throughout the book as this kind of foreboding landscape where they might, you know,
几乎超自然的中间空间。我认为因为那种神秘感，不是陆地，不是水，不是完全活着，不是完全死亡，它们对我们来说真的非常迷人。所以，电影、流行文化、文学中的沼泽通常代表人们可以躲避社会的地方，或者你可能迷路的地方。这在书籍和电影中完全是真的。就像我记得在《呼啸山庄》中，你知道，你有荒原（Moors），它们在整本书中经常被呈现为一种预示性的景观，在那里他们可能，你知道，
Catherine Heathcliff might get lost or drowned or in Lord of the Rings. They sort of wind their way through these marshes that are filled with dead faces looking up at them. There are dead things! Dead faces in the water! When I was a kid, the one that really got me was the swamp of sadness and the never-ending story. You know, where his horse actually gets swallowed up in it.
凯瑟琳·希斯克利夫可能会迷路或淹死，或者在《指环王》中。他们穿过这些沼泽，里面充满了抬头看着他们的死脸。有死东西！水里有死脸！当我还是个孩子的时候，真正让我印象深刻的是《大魔域》中的悲伤沼泽。你知道，他的马实际上被它吞没了。
It's just so tragic, so upsetting. Yeah, totally. I almost pulled a clip from that, but it was like too kind of unpleasant to listen to this little boy screaming about his drowning horse. It's very sad. The one that really comes to mind for me is the Princess Bride. You know, the characters are traversing or navigating their way through a fire swamp, where, you know, bursts of flames come up through the soil and they have to dodge these hazards.
这太悲惨了，太令人不安了。是的，完全。我差点从那里剪辑一段，但这听起来太令人不快了，听这个小男孩尖叫着关于他溺水的马。这非常悲伤。真正让我想到的是《公主新娘》。你知道，角色们正在穿过或导航穿过一个火沼泽，在那里，你知道，火焰从土壤中喷涌而出，他们必须躲避这些危险。
I mean, what are the three terrors of the fire swamp? One, the flames burn. No problem. There's a popping sound proceeding each week and avoid that. Two, the lightning sound, but you will clever enough to discover what that looks like. So in the future, we can avoid that, too.
我的意思是，火沼泽的三大恐怖是什么？一，火焰燃烧。没问题。每次喷发前都有爆裂声，避开那个。二，闪电声，但你足够聪明，发现了那是什么样子的。所以将来，我们也可以避开那个。
Bessling, what about the RRUSs? Rodents of unusual size? I don't think they exist. AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH white as far fetched as you might imagine. There are gases, some of them are flammable that are produced in these very wet saturated bog systems. We don't often see flames leaping up through a bog system, but there is a lot of methane produced because of this really anaerobic decomposition. And that methane actually could be flammable.
Bessling，那RRUS呢？异常巨大的啮齿动物？我不认为它们存在。啊——（此处省略一长串尖叫）——其实并没有你想象的那么牵强。在这些非常潮湿、饱和的泥炭沼泽系统中，会产生一些气体，其中一些是易燃的。我们不常看到火焰从沼泽系统中窜出，但由于这种真正的厌氧分解，确实产生了大量的甲烷。而这些甲烷实际上可能是易燃的。
I mean, that is shocking that that could be based in any kind of reality. I mean, come to think of it, you know, the dead people in the bogs like the Lord of the Rings, that also feels like a reference to the bog people that we touch on in the main body of the episode. Right, bog bodies. Yeah. And so, you know, in general, I think bogs are portrayed as these kind of dark, scary places as we've seen throughout this. And like, usually there is some truth to that.
我的意思是，这令人震惊，它竟然有任何现实基础。想想看，你知道，《指环王》里沼泽里的死人，那也感觉像是对我们在本集正文中提到的沼泽尸体的引用。没错，沼泽尸体。所以，总的来说，我认为沼泽在整个过程中都被描绘成那种黑暗、可怕的地方。而且通常情况下，这确实有一定道理。
Like, they are hard to walk through and you can get stuck in the mud and there are weird gases. So it's like, it's like a caricature based in some amount of real, real accurate details of what it's like, but it also falls really short and fully appreciating them for the incredible places that they are. Yeah, so I have to admit, bugs are like my favorite ecosystem. I think there's so cool. I used to study botany in the Midwest. There's much more bugs. There's no bugs here in the really in the West Coast to speak up, but there's real bogs there. I like a cranberry bog.
比如，它们很难行走，你可能会陷进泥里，还有奇怪的气体。所以这就像是一个基于一些真实、准确细节的讽刺画，但它在充分欣赏沼泽作为不可思议的地方这一点上，也确实做得不够。是的，所以我必须承认，沼泽是我最喜欢的生态系统。我觉得它们太酷了。我过去在中西部学习植物学。那里有更多的沼泽。在西海岸这里几乎没有什么沼泽可言，但那里有真正的沼泽。我喜欢蔓越莓沼泽。
I like a quaking bog. I mean, a quaking bog is like with a spagnum rose so thick that trees can grow on it. And if you get enough people, they can jump on the spagnum and trees can sway from you jumping on the ground. It is like, bogs are amazing. I love them.
我喜欢震颤沼泽。我的意思是，震颤沼泽就像是有着厚厚的泥炭藓，树木可以在上面生长。如果你有足够多的人，他们可以在泥炭藓上跳跃，树木会因为你在地面上的跳跃而摇晃。这就像是，沼泽太神奇了。我爱它们。
Yeah, I wanted to pitch this story because I wanted to go to Scotland and check out these bugs, because I also think bugs. I'm so sorry. And then that immediately became an impossibility with the COVID situation. But can I share one cool bug fact
是的，我想推销这个故事，因为我想去苏格兰看看这些沼泽，因为我也认为沼泽……我很抱歉。然后这立刻因为新冠疫情的情况变得不可能了。但我能分享一个很酷的沼泽事实吗？
that I didn't get to work into the story? No, absolutely go for it. So did you know that bugs breathe? No, So did you know that bogs breathe? No, I did not know that. So there's this common phenomenon in Peteland science called bog breathing. And what we mean by that is that the surface of a bog, the surface of the vegetation layer moves up and down.
我没能把它写进故事里？不，绝对可以，请讲。你知道沼泽会呼吸吗？不，你知道沼泽会呼吸吗？不，我不知道。在泥炭地科学中有一个常见的现象叫“沼泽呼吸”。我们的意思是，沼泽的表面，即植被层的表面，会上下移动。
It expands or it shrinks, depending on the hydrology and where the water table is sitting. And this is actually an adaptive trait. It means when conditions are wet, the water table adjusts and the whole peat layer adjusts to that shift. When things get dry, again, that pit layer responds. So, it's not really breathing as in like respiration.
它会根据水文学和地下水位的位置而膨胀或收缩。这实际上是一种适应性特征。这意味着当条件潮湿时，地下水位会调整，整个泥炭层也会随之调整。当情况变干时，泥炭层也会做出反应。所以，这并不是真正的呼吸，就像那种呼吸作用一样。
It's more like a metaphor of movement when they say bog breathing. Yeah, yeah. It's almost like, I like think of it as like, the bog is like a, like a giant's belly that's like rising and falling as the ecosystem sort ecosystem breathes in and out. It takes on more space and pushes up to the sky. Almost like your diaphragm would expand when you're taking a deep breath, but then that can also contract down and that breath is then expelled. This isn't a new phenomenon like scientists have known about
当他们说“沼泽呼吸”时，这更像是一种运动的隐喻。是的，是的。我喜欢把它想象成，沼泽就像一个巨人的肚子，随着生态系统的吸气和呼气而起伏。它占据了更多的空间并向上推向天空。就像你深呼吸时横膈膜会扩张，但随后它也会收缩，那口气就被呼出了。这不是一个新现象，科学家们早就知道了
bog breathing for a really long time. But it's incredibly difficult to measure. So this is Roxanne Anderson again. So if you think about it, trying to go and measure how much the surface moves up and down, and that's in the order of millimeters, you know, if you try to measure that by walking onto the bog, which is an unstable and wobbly surface, it's going to be very difficult. Right. It's like trying to measure the surface of a water bed. It constantly moves underneath your feet. That must be really frustrating if you're trying to measure it.
沼泽呼吸已经很久了。但它极其难以测量。所以这是Roxanne Anderson再次发言。所以如果你想一下，试图去测量表面上下移动了多少，而且是在毫米量级的，你知道，如果你试图通过走到沼泽上来测量，那是一个不稳定且摇晃的表面，这将非常困难。没错。这就像试图测量水床的表面。它在你脚下不断移动。如果你试图测量它，那一定非常令人沮丧。
Yeah, exactly. And so Roxanne Anderson and her colleagues have been looking at ways that they could measure this without actually going out and trying to measure the surface manually. And what we've been looking at is using satellites that uses radar. So basically using radar from a satellite to send a signal down to the bog every few days and getting measurements on how that surface level is changing over time.
是的，完全正确。所以Roxanne Anderson和她的同事们一直在寻找一种方法，可以在不亲自出去手动测量表面的情况下测量它。我们一直在研究的是使用使用雷达的卫星。所以基本上是利用卫星的雷达每隔几天向沼泽发送一个信号，并获得关于表面水平随时间变化的测量结果。
What Roxanne and her colleagues have been trying to figure out is like, can they use that bog breathing pattern and getting measurements on how that surface level is changing over time. What Roxanne and her colleagues have been trying to figure out is can they use that bog breathing pattern from the satellite data as an indicator of the overall health of the Pete Land? It's like a doctor putting a stethoscope to your back and saying, deep breath. Right, exactly. And I think gathering that data could help scientists understand
Roxanne和她的同事们一直试图弄清楚的是，他们能否利用那种沼泽呼吸模式并获得关于表面水平随时间变化的测量结果。Roxanne和她的同事们一直试图弄清楚的是，他们能否利用卫星数据中的那种沼泽呼吸模式作为泥炭地整体健康状况的指标？这就像医生把听诊器放在你的背上说，深呼吸。没错，完全正确。而且我认为收集这些数据可以帮助科学家了解
whether a Peteland is functioning as a healthy Peteland and a robust carbon sink or whether it's degraded in some way that you maybe didn't know and might be actually emitting carbon. So what's the pattern they're finding? And like, how do you tell if the breathing of a bog is healthy or not? Yeah, I asked Roxanne that.
泥炭地是否作为一个健康的泥炭地和强大的碳汇在发挥作用，或者它是否以某种你可能不知道的方式退化了，并且实际上可能正在排放碳。那么他们发现的模式是什么？以及，你如何判断沼泽的呼吸是否健康？是的，我问了Roxanne这个问题。
So what we've found is that kind of healthy peatland, if you like, they have one peaking one trough roughly every year. And the peak is usually, if they're really healthy, it's usually going to be in the autumn, with quite a high amplitude. And then the trough is going to be in the spring. So a high amplitude and then the trough is going to be in the spring. So you have this kind of cycle of peaks and troughs. So one big breath in and one big breath out every year. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And then the more degree that it gets, the more it just becomes kind of no peaks, no troughs, just kind of a flatter line. Well, you don't want to
所以我们发现的是，那种健康的泥炭地，如果你愿意的话，它们大约每年有一个波峰和一个波谷。如果它们非常健康，波峰通常会在秋季，振幅相当高。然后波谷会在春季。所以有一个高振幅，然后波谷会在春季。所以你会有这种波峰和波谷的循环。所以每年有一次大吸气和一次大呼气。是的，是的，是的，是的。然后它退化得越严重，它就越变得没有波峰，没有波谷，只是一条比较平坦的线。好吧，你不想
see a flat line like an EKG, you don't want that. Right. Right. And you know, Roxanne says that this new way of gathering bog breathing data is actually like really important or could be really, really important for Peteland conservation globally. I think that the interesting thing for me about this is that it completely changes the way that we can understand Pitland globally because we can just do that, you know, if we spend the time to do the validation like we've done here for any type of Pitland, you might end up with knowing what the signal or the breathing pattern for a particular type of Pitland is and
看到像心电图那样的平线，你不想那样。没错。没错。而且你知道，Roxanne说这种收集沼泽呼吸数据的新方法实际上非常重要，或者在全球泥炭地保护方面可能非常、非常重要。我认为对我来说，这件事有趣的地方在于，它彻底改变了我们全球理解泥炭地的方式，因为我们可以直接这样做，你知道，如果我们花时间进行像我们在这里所做的验证，针对任何类型的泥炭地，你最终可能会知道特定类型泥炭地的信号或呼吸模式，并且
you might be able to detect anomalies that are diagnostic of degradation for beatlands that are impossible to reach or very, very difficult to reach that really remote or impossible to visit on a regular basis. And this is really important because so many beatlands are in these remote locations, and they're their places that humans have tended to avoid. And we're actually still discovering new petalins and often they're really hard to access. And so it could be this really helpful tool in mapping and understanding the role that petalins
你可能能够检测到诊断退化的异常情况，对于那些无法到达或非常、非常难以到达的泥炭地，那些非常偏远或无法定期访问的地方。这非常重要，因为许多泥炭地都在这些偏远的地方，而且它们是人类倾向于避开的地方。而且我们实际上仍在发现新的泥炭地，通常它们真的很难进入。所以这可能成为绘制和理解泥炭地作用的一个非常有用的工具
are playing as carbon sinks or as carbon sources. I mean, one of the things that I think is really interesting about the story is that the petalins are doing a lot of good if they're healthy, but if they're not healthy, they're actually kind of a problem because they release that carbon that they've stored. Right, exactly. It's super important that we find out where they are and monitor them and really are invested in keeping them healthy all around the world. Like it's like all of our well-being is sort of caught up in that carbon beneath these hot spots all over the world. Yeah, oh it's so cool. Well I love bogs even more now. Thank you so much Emmett. Yeah of course.
它们作为碳汇或碳源发挥着作用。我的意思是，我认为这个故事中非常有趣的一点是，如果泥炭地健康，它们会做很多好事，但如果它们不健康，它们实际上是一个问题，因为它们释放了它们储存的碳。没错，完全正确。我们找出它们在哪里并监测它们，并且真正投入到保持它们在全球范围内的健康是非常重要的。就像我们所有人的福祉都与世界各地这些热点下方的碳息息相关。是的，哦，这太酷了。好吧，我现在更喜欢沼泽了。非常感谢你，Emmett。是的，当然。
99% invisible was produced so sweet by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Bryson Barnes, music by Sean Rial. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstad is the digital director, Resa team is Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Chris Barube, Joe Rosenberg, Katie Mingle, Abby Madonna, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Jesse Reynolds from UCLA, who we also spoke to for this story, and also to writers Virginia Guen and Sharon Levy, whose articles about the flow country got us interested in the region. If you want to read more about Pete Linge Restoration in Scotland,
99% Invisible由Emmett Fitzgerald制作，Bryson Barnes混音，Sean Rial配乐。我们的高级制作人是Delaney Hall，Kurt Colstad是数字总监，制作团队包括Christopher Johnson、Vivian Leigh、Chris Barube、Joe Rosenberg、Katie Mingle、Abby Madonna、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。本周特别感谢来自加州大学洛杉矶分校的Jesse Reynolds，我们也为这个故事采访了他，还要感谢作家Virginia Guen和Sharon Levy，他们关于Flow Country的文章让我们对该地区产生了兴趣。如果你想阅读更多关于苏格兰泥炭地恢复的内容，
we have links to their fantastic articles on our website, it's 9iMPI.org. We are a project of 91.7K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which lives at the far corners of North America, but is centered and beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
我们在我们的网站上有他们精彩文章的链接，网址是9iMPI.org。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，它位于北美最遥远的角落，但位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，美丽且处于中心位置。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的创始成员，这是一个极其独立的集体，
of the most innovative lists that are supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 9-9-PI org on Instagram and read it too. You can now order our first book, the 99% Invisible City, at 99pi.org-flashbook. We have links to purchase it anywhere you get your books, including Signed Editions and the Audio Book. And if you did get the book and enjoyed it,
由世界上最创新的、100%艺术家拥有的播客支持。在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，在Instagram和Reddit上关注节目@99pi.org。你现在可以在99pi.org/book订购我们的第一本书《99% Invisible City》。我们有链接可以让你在任何购买书籍的地方购买它，包括签名版和有声书。如果你买了这本书并喜欢它，
review it somewhere. That's a huge boost to us. For all your other 99pi needs, look no further at 99opia.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在某个地方评论它。这对我们是一个巨大的推动。对于你所有其他的99pi需求，请访问99pi.org。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。